can you see the screen MH okay
great all right
awesome all right let me introduce you
um welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
uh before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk but if you have
questions you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences uh therefore no classified
discussion is allowed uh finally The
Talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel oh that's about
it let me briefly introduce our speaker
today it is an honor to host Dr Alberto
p van who is a post-doctoral
researcher uh in the department of
aerospace engineering at the University
of Illinois Oran campaign he obtained
his PhD from Princeton University in
August 2022 and his research interests
lie at the intersection of fluid
mechanics dynamical systems and control
theory Alberto's current work focuses on
the development of data driven methods
for model reduction of fluid flows as
well as on the analysis and control of
Supersonic and Hypersonic wall bounded
flows today Alberto will talk about data
driven model reduction via non-intrusive
optimization of projection operators and
redu to the Dynamics I'm sure we are
going to hear a wonderful talk from him
um now let me um ask a somewhat informal
questions to Alberto uh just to get to
know him better here we go are you ready
M to ready all right this is the best
random question I came up with after
hearing about your background I happen
to know you you love soccer and if you
can
share your favorite soccer player um in
history in history not not just uh in
history favorite soccer player um I
would say uh Paulo Malini was the uh AC
Milan captain yeah I I'll go with him if
I had to choose one yeah do you do do
you have the reason uh well he was the
he was the captain of uh my uh my
favorite team for a long time and uh I
guess he known as one of the best
defenders uh uh to ever play the game so
a yeah that's why very great okay um
it's stage is stage is years Al to uh
what was that stage each years it's it's
your time to give your presentation yeah
okay thank you Dr Choy for uh uh for U
inviting me uh at the ddps seminar
series uh today I'll talk about um
datadriven model reduction via
non-inclusive optimization of projection
operators and reduced order Dynamics and
here's a the outline of my talk I'll go
over a a few slides of introduction and
motivation and I'm sure that uh most if
not all of you are familiar with some of
the some of the concepts I'll be talking
about um then I'll go over a an overview
of some existing formulations we'll
touch upon Petro galery models which are
intrusive and then uh we'll talk about
an existing non-intrusive formulation
which is known as operator inference
after that uh I'll present the uh the
main topic of this of this presentation
which is nitron this is a it's a
non-intrusive trajectory based
optimization of reduced order models uh
and is an extension of of existing
methods that we've recently come up with
uh and then uh I'll show some examples
we have three examples of increasing
complexity a to a toy model uh a
onedimensional pte and then the
two-dimensional The Driven cavity flow
okay so uh even though I'm sure that
most of you are familiar with the
overarching idea of model reduction I
thought it'd be good to uh uh to set
some foundations uh just in case and and
and so physical systems that we're
interested in interested in studying or
simulating like fluids or solids are
described by partial differential
equations
and after spatial discretization we
obtain systems of Odes with many degrees
of freedom so here's a brief example we
have the incompressible number Stokes
equations and after spatial
discretization using finite difference
fin a volume finite element you name it
your your favorite spatial
discretization scheme we obtain a system
of Odes where here for instance U subd
is the velocity on a on a mesh and PD is
the pressure uh and uh and Q is the is
the spatially discretized state and so
the main challenge associated with this
high dimensionality is computational
cost and uh this can come in many
flavors but uh most notably uh one is
the cost associated with uh integrating
equation one in time uh and number two
could be uh related to the cursor
dimensionality during tasks such as
optimization control design and system
analysis so to reduce cost we'd like to
find a reduced order model uh which is a
system uh given in equation 2 that
behaves like equation one in some sense
but it's much cheaper to work with and
the reason why it's cheaper to work with
is because the uh reduced order model
State Z has Dimension that is usually
much slower than the dimension of Q so
we can integrate uh and work with
equation 2 in a u in a more
computationally efficient manner all
right so there are many approaches and
many decades of literature on uh mod
reduction for for physical systems but
most of them tend to T to share this uh
this type of architecture that I'll
discuss in a second uh so the first step
is we we start from the uh what we call
the full order model or the F uh this is
this specially discretized number Stokes
equations if you're working with fluids
Q is the is the state Vector could be
the velocity density or any any flow
variable you're interested in uh and U
in in case there's a uh there's control
input for instance uh could be a
boundary forcing a volumetric forcing uh
whatever type of actuate uh control
input you might have on your on your
system and so A reduced order model uh
can be described schematically as
follows we have three components we have
an encoder a decoder and ROM Dynamics uh
so the decoder is a possibly nonlinear
function that takes you from the high
dimensional space uh onto a low
dimensional space this this could be a
linear Subspace or a nonlinear manifold
uh and so basically this operation is
that of of of of a compression so we'll
go from high dimension to low Dimension
once we're in low Dimensions uh we have
the ROM dynamics that uh evolve the low
dimensional State uh in time
and then finally we have a decoder uh
which goes which is is a possibly
nonlinear map from the low dimensional
space to the high dimensional space and
gives us uh this quantity Q hat which is
the approximate solution uh q and
hopefully uh once we've gone through
this pipeline Q hat is not so far away
from the ground truth solution q and as
I was saying there are many different
approaches to uh uh to this and and that
gives the literature so the encoder and
decoder it could be linear it could be
nonlinear um uh the encoder and decoder
could be constrained to define a
projection so where for instance uh the
the uh encoder is is a left inverse of
decoder and so we are implicitly
defining a a projection and then also uh
it could be intrusive or non- intrusive
in the sense that um uh the computations
that give us um uh FM si uh could be
relying on the full order model or could
be relying exclusively on data without
any knowledge of the governing equations
that uh uh generated the data itself and
then as far as the round Dynamics go we
could have uh continuous time Dynamics
uh discrete time Dynamics and again they
could be computed intrusively or uh non
intrusively uh depending on the specific
application all right so on today's talk
we're going to constraint ourselves uh
to encoder and decoders that are linear
so they can be represented as uh n by R
matrices in this specific case uh also
we constrain them to Define a linear
projection uh so here you see that the
uh the encoder uh is a left inverse of
of the decoder by Design and then also
the reduced order model Dynamics are
continuous in time and so today's
overarching question is how do we learn
fee s and the ROM Dynamics G non-
intrusively uh with the additional
constraint then FMI Define an oblique
projection all right so why do we insist
on projections in the first place so uh
as I said before if the encoder is the
left inverse of the decoder then we're
implicit ly defining a projection
operator which I call P and if p is
equal to P then the projection is
orthogonal and if they're not equal then
the projection is uh oblique so here's a
here's a schematic of uh what an
orthogonal and oblique projections do so
if we have a threedimensional vector Q
in threedimensional space uh and we have
a Target Subspace uh which is the span
of Fe then an orthogonal projection uh
will basically take q and project it
onto fe uh in the direction of the
orthogonal complement of Fe um but if we
want to have an oblique projection
instead we need an additional component
which is another Subspace s I'm sorry
the another Subspace which is given by
the span of s and so uh the oblique
projection will take the vector q and
project it onto onto the span of Fe
along the orthogonal complement of uh of
the span of s and so in general we like
projections because if if the vector Q
lies in the range of the projection uh
then basically project the the
projection operator P Act is effectively
the identity uh operate operator on on
its range and So intuitively speaking
and from from a physical standpoint this
means that the operation of encoding and
decoding the F state does not introduce
a spe drift in the ROM state so
basically what we're saying if the ROM
Dynam if the reduced order model state
is evolving uh we want it to be evolving
because of the ROM Dynamics not because
of the of the operation of encoding and
decoding going from high dimensional to
low dimensional space so this is uh
Loosely speaking the reason why we like
projections now why do we like oblique
projections so there's many reasons why
we you know going over all the reasons
why it would take a lot of time uh but
in general uh we need oblique
projections for uh systems that are
commonly referred to as non-normal and
so where uh um Loosely speaking uh low
energy states that we might not be able
to see in a Sim
are nonetheless dynamically important
and so to capture those types of
mechanisms we need oblique projections
so I thought I'd give you an example of
uh the reason why oblique projections
are good so this is not quite an
explanation of uh why we need them but
more so evidence of the fact that we do
need them so uh as a simple example here
we have a the the complex ginsborg low
equation uh we'll go back to a
description of it uh in in in a little
bit but for for now the important thing
is that we have a 1D PD and we'd like to
be able to compute reduced order models
that are uh that can predict the time
history of the output y uh in response
to some input U uh and so that that's
the name of the game so instead of
solving this pde uh we want in this
specific case five dimensional reduced
order models that can tell us what
happens to why as we force the system
with some unknown unseen input U and so
uh I'll try to unpack unpack this figure
uh as best I can so what we did here is
we forced equation for with an Impulse
so we uh started from nonzero initial
condition uh in the span of B at initial
time and then we let the simulation go
and we compute U uh I'm sorry Y and so
the ground Truth uh history of the
output Y is given by the black line and
then what we do here is we use four
different model reduction approaches to
compute five-dimensional reduced order
models and I'll describe each one of
them uh in detail in a little bit but uh
for now the important thing is the
following so we have the first two
methods are uh one is intrusive and the
other one is not intrusive but the
important thing is that they they both
rely on orthogonal projections onto a
low dimensional Subspace the bottom two
are one is intrusive the other one is
non intrusive and it's the one I'll be
talking about uh mostly today but the
more the most important thing is that uh
they compress the data using oblique
projections and you see the striking
difference between uh the predicted
capabilities of models that use oblique
projections over models that use
orthogonal projections both models using
oblique projections are doing a great
job at tracking the ground truth history
of the output uh whereas the the the
models that rely on orthogonal
projections are not doing that that
great a job and this is also true for a
different type of input uh we're forcing
with a sinusoid now uh but the the
picture Remains qualitatively the Same
in the sense that uh oblique protection
ROMs are doing a good job of tracking
the output whereas orthogonal protection
ROMs are uh are not really uh giving us
good pred prediction uh of what happens
to Y in response to U all right so I
hope this this was uh I guess convincing
evidence enough of of of the reason why
we need oblique projections uh for uh
for model reduction so here's an
overview of uh some existing
formulations um so perhaps the most
well-known uh uh approach for uh to
obtain a reduced D model is is petal
luring uh and so this is an intrusive
approach and Computing the reduced T
model requires knowledge and access to
the full order governing equ governing
equations and so if we have the if the
the F equations are given by equation
five this again could be the the
spatially discretized N Stokes equations
then the Petro galeran Dynamics are
given by equation six and what equation
six is telling us that is that uh we are
constraining uh the state q uh to the
range of the projection for all times
and also uh not only are we projecting
the state onto the range of P but we're
also projecting the Dynamics F onto the
range of p and so we obtain this uh this
model that uh is to be designed in such
a way that uh Q hat is as close as
possible uh to uh the original uh the
original state q uh and so even though
the state q hat in this specific the way
of written it has the same dimension of
the state q uh the Dynamics in six can
be realized by a low dimensional system
where the dimension uh of the state Z is
that of the rank of the projection and
so we see that uh
basically the takeaway from this slide
is that petaler model the the degrees of
freedom in petaler model so what we uh
what we get to choose are uh the
matrices FMI but once we choose th those
the ROM Dynamics are uh fully determined
by fepi and by the full order Dynamics f
um I would like to point out that
actually uh we don't need to specify FMI
more so as the their span so really a
Peter model is not a function of of the
matrices FMI but rather a function of
the the the spaces that they span and
we'll we'll come back to that in a in a
little bit so the name so question is
how do we pick FMI there different ways
to do that perhaps the most uh popular
one is uh
pod fodal lurking is a weakly intrusive
approach and it's uh historically the
simplest way to choose FM side in fact
it goes like this we collect data from a
full order
simulation uh we stack it into a matrix
and we take it SVD uh then what we do is
we retain the first R Columns of U uh we
call these the leading r pod modes and
then we simply set F equal toi equal to
the first rpod modes uh once we have fee
we can easily compute uh the ROM
Dynamics as shown uh in bullet point 3
and so this implicitly defines an
orthogonal projection onto the range of
the Pod modes uh and the ROM is known as
a gurin model um and so from an in
standpoint what we're doing here is we
are projecting the governing equations
onto the span of the most energetic uh
features uh of of uh of the system
however uh as as as as as I discussed
briefly a few minutes ago there might be
uh non-energetic states that are
dynamically relevant so that's that's
when we need oblique projections
and so uh a common way to get an oblique
projection is balance truncation and so
and it it was uh was first developed in
1981 so it's a somewhat old formulation
uh and it's a tool from linear control
theory and the method is highly
intrusive and I'll describe in a in a
minute what I what I mean by it and so
um balance proc balance truncation
procedes as follows we start from the
nonlinear governing equations and first
step is we need to linearize about a
fixed point so here a is the
linearization of of f uh uh is the
derivative of f with respect to State
and the input Matrix u b is the
derivative of f with respect to the
control input and so now we've obtain
we've we've obtained a linear timing
baring system uh which we can work with
we we like LTI systems because we kind
of know everything there's to know about
LTI systems and we can work with them
pretty easily and so the the name of the
game in balance truncation is the follow
is is is is the following we want to
find and truncate a set of coordinates
where the controllability and
observability gramms are equal and
diagonal now the the specific details
are are not important but basically to
find FM s we need to compute uh these
integrals in the parenthesis and you see
that these integrals which are the
gramians depend on a and a star which is
the ad joint of a and so in that sense
uh this method is very intrusive because
uh we cannot treat the solver as a
blackbox we have to go into the solver
we have to linearize it then we have to
compute it adile so that those are very
uh intrusive operations in any case once
we have FMI we can compute we can go
back to our nonlinear system and we can
obtain a peteran representation of it as
follows so as I was saying uh this
method is very intrusive because not
only do we need to query F to compute
ROM Dynamics but we also need to access
the linearization and its agine around a
steady state so that's that's an
intrusive uh um that's that's an
intrusive operation uh the third uh
approach I'll be discussing today uh
really briefly is is an ol formulation
that we developed a couple years ago um
and it's called troop it's trajectory
based optimization of oblique
projections and uh it produces a a ROM
as follows the the the actual concept is
is pretty straightforward uh we collect
rectory data and we and and we save it
from from a full order simulation and
then uh what we want to do is we want to
find subspaces uh B and W that define an
oblique projection uh that minimize the
SC function uh which is just the mean
square error between the the ground
truth data and the and the Bron
prediction subject to a petrop alerin
model uh of this form so remember that
as I said before a noblique projection
is not really a function of FM but it's
a function of the subspaces V and W that
they span so the optimization problem is
carried out in terms of these subspaces
and the appropriate optimization space
is the grasp and manifold and we'll
we'll come back to that uh in in a
second once we discuss uh nitron but the
takea away from this is this is an
extremely intrusive procedure so if you
want to compute the gradient of the cost
function with respect to the subspaces
then uh you can sort of see how we'll
have to compute uh the linearization of
F and its adint along entire entire
trajectory so the the reduced order
model is a function of FMI but these
fed into the cfd solver so if you want
to compute gradients we'll have to
differentiate the cfd solver and that's
uh that's extremely intrusive um okay so
uh enough with intrusive methods we
we'll move on to uh to uh one uh
intrusive a non-intrusive formulation
which is operator inference which is
very much related to uh to nitron uh as
we'll we'll see in a second so uh I'll
provide a brief description of it uh
here so as we were saying in petery
models the only thing that we can choose
are
FMI uh and then the ROM Dynamics G are
tied to the F Dynamics F in purely data
driven methods we can also choose G as a
matter of fact we're forced to because
data is the only thing that we have to
uh to back out G we cannot really access
the the governing equations and so
operator inference proceeds as follows
the first step is we collect data from
from a representative trajectory and we
do pod and uh we uh we let FM equal b
equal to equal to the Pod mode so we're
implicitly defining we're compressing
the data from a high dimensional space
to the low dimensional space uh via
orthogonal projection onto the span of
pod modes and so the second step is the
following well as I just said we we
compress the data onto the span of pod
modes and we get uh coefficients Z but
we also uh want to get the coefficients
uh we also want to get the time rate of
change of those coefficients so we we we
take the time derivative of the full
order State and we projected onto the
span of the Pod modes and so assuming
that uh the reduced order Dynamics are
polinomial form so they can be written
as uh as as as as in this equation here
uh operator inference solves uh this Le
squares problem where basically we we
want to find reduced order tensors a HB
and however many others that minimize
the difference between the ROM Dynamics
and the time rate of change of the
projection of the f State onto the Pod
modes uh on on on the span of the Pod
modes so basically in in operator
inference we set the encoder decoder to
be given by the Pod modes that defines
an orthogonal projection and on the span
of those modes we want to find uh
polinomial Dynamics uh by fitting uh
tensors okay great so this is kind of uh
the overview of the methods that are uh
inherently connected with with nitron
which which I'll be talking about in a
second uh I'd like to point out that
there are many different other ways to
to do model reduction as I said in the
introduction discrete time uh uh uh
discrete time Dynamics uh nonlinear
encoder decoders but uh as far as we're
concerned today this is uh what we will
be uh comparing nitrum against so here
we go so this is non-intrusive
trajectory based optimization of reduced
or models and uh this method kind of
brings together Concepts both from
intrusive model and uh and from operator
inference but the the the beauty of it
is that uh we we we will not need access
to the governing equations and we can do
the optimization purely from data and so
loosely speaking is what we do is we
simultaneously non intrusively look for
optimal th S and G given full order
trajectories and so uh this is the full
order model um here again this could be
any uh spatially discretized PD we have
an initial condition condition q and
then also we might be interested in some
observable why uh this could be uh
pressure at a wall could be sheer stress
could be the velocity profile somewhere
uh on on your computational grid and
then what we're looking for are reduced
order models of this form so uh we have
the the Dynamics of uh of the ROM
evolving the the coefficients on the
span of a projection that will be
defined shortly uh the initial condition
is the projection of the initial
condition of the farm onto the span of
Fe and then we have the predicted output
y
hat and so uh a couple of things I want
to I want to discuss a couple of things
before we lay we we we lay down the uh
the optimization problem in mathematical
terms the first thing that we observe is
that the ROM is not a function of Fe
itself is a function of of of of the
Subspace that span by Fe and so in fact
you can it can be shown that for any
invertible Matrix uh Matrix uh M of size
R by R uh this relationship holds this
means that uh if we stretch and rotate
uh Fe we're not changing the reduced D
model uh so our dimensional subspaces of
RN are elements of the grasp and
manifold uh and so we'll be looking for
an optimal V uh on uh on the on the
grasp and
manifold uh a similar symmetry does not
hold from s in fact there exist
invertible R byr matrices M uh where uh
equal where this equality doesn't hold
so meaning that if we're if we rotate
and stretch SI we do change the reduced
order model and so uh the ROM is not a
function of the span of s but rather a
function of s itself uh nonetheless we
want s to have rank R otherwise we
wouldn't be able to define a projection
and so uh without loss of generality we
can take s to be an element of the
steifel manifold uh which is the space
of orthonormal n byr matrices and the
third assumption well
well the the the Assumption we make next
on the ROM Dynamics is that they are
polinomial and so we we're kind of
borrowing this from operator inference
that we described a minute ago and so
yeah we're saying the polinomial
Dynamics are polinomial uh the ROM
Dynamics are polinomial so uh the
parameters we'll have to learn from data
are these tensors a h and b uh in Red so
altogether the uh the red quantities on
this slide are uh the ones we will be
try to fit will will try to fit from
data okay so mathematically this is the
optimization problem so we have uh
ground truth observations from the F
called y collected at at some temporal
temporal instances TI and then we have a
reduced order model of polinomial form
that will give us a prediction y hat at
the same at the same uh at the same
times and what we want to do is we want
to minimize this cost function uh by
choosing uh a Subspace B on the grasman
manifold a uh a NR Matrix on the on the
Ste manifold and reduced order tensors
that Define the Dynamics and so the
optimization uh is carried out on this
product manifold of the grasman steel
and as many linear spaces as uh the
number of tensors that we're trying to
fit from
data okay so how do we compute the
gradient so the the the the trick is
that this manifold M that we've just
defined maybe it's best if I go back
it's an abstract manifold it's abstract
in the sense that The Grassman is a is a
is a manifold of subspaces and subspaces
are uh uh abstract entities that we
cannot represent on a computer the only
way we can represent Subspace B on a
computer is indirectly through through
fee and then V is equal to the range of
Fe so how do we uh how do we uh deal
with this abstraction the way to do it
is to work uh to view the steifel and
the grasp and manifolds as
submanifolds of an ambient space whose
object whose elements can be represented
easily on a computer so Ste can be
viewed as an embedded sub manifold of
ukian space of matrices of size n by R
and then if we Define a metric on this
space uh the the steifel manifold will
inherit it and the grasper manifold can
be viewed as a quotient manifold of the
non orthogonal steal manifold so these
are uh these are this is the space of uh
n by r atries uh of rank R um and so
again if we Define the um a met a metric
on this base then the Gras manifold will
inherit it um once we've done that uh it
is possible to define the gradient of
the cost function uh in terms of ukian
space objects so for instance we can we
we can Define the gradient of the cost
function with respect to with respect to
the Subspace V in terms of in terms of
of of fee and so we can easily compute
that on uh on a computer and so the
approach is is quite standard we have
our cost we we use the method of lrange
multipliers we have our cost function we
append uh the constraints uh and here
Lambda are the lrange multipliers uh uh
it can be shown that these satisfy a
reduced order adjoint equations and then
once we once we turn the crank on
calculus variations uh it can be shown
that the gradients uh that the gradient
of the cost function with respect to the
parameters can be computed in closed
form so for instance just to give you a
sense of what this might look like the
gradient of L with respect to a looks
like this right and so uh you can think
of and and the procedure that gives you
the gradient is uh it's it's it's it's
very much akin to a back propagation uh
when you're training neural networks uh
the the I guess the the the the beauty
of the way we laid out the problem is
that the the gradient of of our quote
unquote neural network uh it can be
computed in close form and so we don't
need automatic differentiation to carry
out this
optimization all right so uh I guess
it's it's time for uh for some results
now and we'll look at three different
examples toy model a 1D PD and a lid
driven cavity flow so the toy model is a
system of uh three
Odes uh it's it's very simple system uh
we State X1 X2 and X3 we have an input U
and what we're interested in is uh in uh
um the time history of the outut Y in
response to input c um this new here is
a parameter uh that we've introduced to
show the the need for oblique
projections versus orthogonal
projections so if you take if new is
very small or even new or even equal to
zero for the sake of the discussion uh
the Dynamics become effectively linear
but most importantly uh they are
governed by a diagonal uh linear
operator diagonal operator is normal uh
and so we
we expect that model reduction
approaches that rely on orthogonal
protections will give us uh good reduced
order models uh instead if new is large
the system is nonlinear but uh but more
importantly the the this nonlinearity
has a special feature so we see that it
depends on X3 and so if you look at what
X3 does X3 is the fastest decaying state
of the system so it decays uh well its
Dynamics are linear and it decays with
the with with rate minus5 uh and so this
X3 is the least
energetic uh state of the system but
nonetheless it has a very large effect
on the Dynamics of X1 X2 so uh if if new
is large of course and so if new is
large we expect that uh we're going to
need oblique projections for model
reduction uh because we oblique
projections give us the possibility of
detecting the fact that low energy
states uh might be very important from
from ad dynamical
standpoint uh okay so we consider two
different cases uh new equal to 5 and
new equal to 20 and we train the models
with with four step responses so we
we'll uh we we have a step input uh U we
put it into the Dynamics and then we
collect the time time history of why in
response to these four uh these four
steps uh just to be clear I'm not making
a we're not Computing a parametric ROM
as a function new we're considering two
separate cases just to show uh when you
may or may not need oblique project C
for mot reduction so here uh we're
showing the average testing error across
100 step responses for new equal to 5
and here for new equal to 20 so we see
that for new equal to 5 we've seen that
the Dynamics are effectively uh linear
and normal so uh all model reduction
approaches including those that use uh
orthogonal projections namely podal
lurking and operator inference are doing
pretty well the error is is very is very
low and even though we're improving on
it with with our formulation there's
really no need for oblique projections
in this specific case but if we if we
turn up the value of new then the
Dynamics uh become more quote unquote
non-normal where the this low energy
state is becoming more dynamically
important and we see that the two model
reduction formulations that Leever
leverage uh oblique projections uh are
performing significantly better than uh
orthogonal projection based reduced
order models and so uh this is uh these
are plots that are uh U computed using
step responses this is what we trained
on but what about different types of
inputs um so here we put in uh sinusoids
and so we didn't train on sinusoids and
and we hope that our uh that our
training has given us models that are
capable of telling us what happens in
response to a different type of input
that we haven't seen before and so if
new is small again and the Dynamics are
effectively normal uh we see that uh all
model reduction formulations are are
doing are doing extremely well there's
no distinction between between them at
least from a qualitative standpoint but
then if we uh if we turn on if we uh
turn up the the value new we start
seeing some some major discrepancies and
we see that uh uh troop and nitrum uh
that Rel oblique projections are
tracking the ground truth output uh very
well uh but the other two formulations
uh are not doing so good a job as it can
be seen from uh from this figure okay so
this is this is all for for uh the
reduced order model we'll move on to a
more complicated system you've already
seen this uh briefly in the um in the
introductory section of of the talk uh
but uh so this is the complex Ginsburg
low equation so this is a
one-dimensional PD uh and um uh where
here new gamma and mu and a are
parameters um we choose them so that the
origin is linearly stable uh the system
however despite the fact that it's
stable uh it will um exhibit large
amplitude Transit growth and this is
this is due to the fact that the uh
linear operator here is it's non normal
uh and so again uh this is one of those
instances where we'll need whether we
work intrusively or non- intrusively we
need to compress the data using oblique
projections um and so the what just just
just for the sake of example what what
we'd like to do is to be able to predict
uh outputs y uh in response to inputs uh
uh B uh bu and so uh here in this figure
I'm showing the spatial distribution of
the input and output operators B and C
here we have B uh in black and and C in
red and so uh from a physical standpoint
we're we're forcing the system uh uh
Upstream uh and we're and we are
observing the response Downstream and
and and this is this is typical of uh
spatially developing flows for instance
where take a j for instance where you
might actuate near the nozzle but then
you want to look at what happens to the
to to to verticity uh Downstream and so
this is this is kind of what we're
trying to uh to emulate here in this
example and we look for models with
Dimension five and we train with four uh
impulse response uh impulse responses uh
so the spatial distribution of the
impulse uh is in the span of B uh what
we what we what we VAR is the amplitude
uh of the impulse magnitude U at time
zero and so uh once we train uh then we
test across 25 uh impulse responses with
unseen amplitudes uh and here we have
again pod Garing operator inference
troop and our formulation nitron and we
see that uh nitr and Troop uh for that
matter uh are uh doing very well uh and
they're uh they're maintaining uh a very
low uh average error uh across time and
here on the right hand side uh is is a
representative uh trajectory of the
output y uh taken from one of these
impulses that we that we tested on and
so we see that um both troop and nitrum
are capable of tracking the ground truth
um time history of the alpha y but the
other two formulations uh with
orthogonal projections uh are not really
uh capable uh of giving us a a a
faithful prediction of of what happens
to the to the full order system in
response to the input and then just for
just to make sure that we've learned
Dynamics and and we haven't overfit uh
impulses uh we uh we change the we
change the forcing input on the left
hand side we're forcing with the sodal
input uh with frequency Omega this is
roughly the natural frequency of of the
full order Dynamics and we see that
we're um again we're tracking the output
uh pretty well um and this is the analog
for the second harmonic of the
fundamental frequency and again we see
that we're we're doing a pretty good job
here as well um you can see some minor
discrepancy
uh here at at at later time uh this is
probably due to the fact that uh the
frequency content to Omega wasn't uh
that dominant in the training data set
so the model hasn't really seen a lot of
two Omega structures uh showing up uh in
uh in the in in the training data set so
uh I I guess that uh the fouring with
with frequency 2 Omega are somewhat out
of distribution for uh nonetheless we're
we're performing uh much better than
than uh uh the other methods uh using
orthogonal projections and much better
than than operator inference which is
non
insures okay so this is the last example
I'll be talking about so this is the uh
I guess the the highest degree of
complex complexity we've considered this
is a uh two-dimensional incompressible
uh lid driven cavity flow at Reynolds
number
8300 um the top boundary uh of of the
domain moves with horizontal velocity U
equal to 1
and we spatially discretize the N Stokes
equations with a finite difference uh uh
scheme on a 100 by 100 grid so what we
want to do here for the sake of example
we want to Mo we want models that are
capable of predicting uh the whole
velocity field so the the the whole uh U
andv velocity field on the whole domain
in response to inputs that enter the
flow via spatially localized body Forest
that is placed uh near the uh top right
corner so you can envision just being
like a a gausian uh spatial profile that
injects U uh that acts as a body force
on the momentum equation of of of of the
fluid um so what we do is we train
reduced order models of Dimension 50
with seven impulse
responses and uh just to give you a
sense for how this flow behaves uh I
I've plotted the energy of the uh
perturbation from the from the training
trajectories um over time and what I
mean by bir perturbations these are uh
fluctuations about uh the study State uh
that exists at rals number 8300 and so
most notably what happens here is that
um after an initial decay in energy uh
the energy spikes back up at roughly at
time equals uh five or six and this is
uh this is typical behavior of of
non-normal systems um where there's
transient energy growth and and in this
specific case it's pretty high amplitude
um if the system was normal then uh the
the energy wouldn't Spike back up and it
would it would keep on decaying back to
zero uh and also I'd like to point out
that uh uh this this figure also
indicates that the system is is quite
nonlinear because uh these uh uh these
lines are not scalar multiples of each
other so if the Dynamics were linear
then uh the these these would be scalar
multiples of each other but they're not
in this case so we're looking at a
nonlinear system uh
that has underlying non-normal like
Dynamics all right so uh we do not apply
troop in this specific case because it's
because it's very intrusive but what we
consider is pret of Garing projection
operator inference and nitr and so this
is the training uh error for the seven
uh trajectories training trajectories we
considered and this is the testing error
for uh uh unseen uh impulses and we see
that uh with nitron we've managed to uh
keep the error pretty low even at times
uh before 10 where we have that huge
spike in energy um in the in the
training trajectories and um and testing
trajectories uh for that matter so the
question we're asking next is okay we we
we have a model that performs pretty
well on uh impulse on on impulses um how
does it perform on unseen inputs and so
as before we forc the system uh Cally
and so we consider we have six different
runs and we consider uh harmonics of the
frequency 1.25 and harmonics of the
frequency one these are frequencies that
are relevant uh for the the full order
uh Dynamics and we see that in all
settings we're doing a really good job
at tracking the the energy the evolution
of the energy of the of the
perturbations uh for as I said uh for
all for all scenarios in particular I
want to point out that um at long time
aside from uh perhaps discrepancies in
amplitude we are uh we're getting the
right phase of these oscillations and
also at Early Times we're we're we're
doing very well at tracking uh the
initial growth uh uh of energy before
the system settles onto a uh onto onto a
force limit cycle um and so this is what
snapshots from these Solutions look like
we have top left the full order model
this is ground this is ground truth
solution computed from cfd this is
nitron uh again these are 50 dimensional
models operator inference and podal
aring you see that podal aring and
operator inference are underestimating
the uh the magnitude of the verticity
that arises in response to these sinodal
inputs but also they're uh they're not
uh predicting the face correctly so if
if you look at this blue vertical
structure here at x equal to 0.5 at the
bottom of the cavity you see that uh
operator inference and uh podal luring
predict structures that are out of phase
uh with that uh that structure by
contrast uh nitron is doing a uh very
good job at at predicting both the
amplitude of the verticity field and the
phase of vertical structures and here's
another set of snapshots for a low
frequency uh forcing input in this case
again nitrum is uh capable of predicting
uh given a good prediction of what
happens to the Flow by contrast operator
inference and P guring are uh uh they
seem to be overestimating the V struct
the vertical uh the magnitude of the
verticity and they are not giving a
faithful
representation of the type of vertical
structures that uh we see in response to
the input okay so in conclusion we have
introduced a novel non-intrusive model
reduction framework for systems that
exhibit large amplitud trans and growth
uh and the key takeaway U is that we
improve on existing non-intrusive
methods by projecting the high
dimensional data onto low dimensional
Subspace via oblique projection and
that's the key the the the Improvement
here is that we're capable of uh
Computing oblique projections directly
from data uh for um for model reduction
uh future work here we're considering
linear projections onto onto linear sub
spaces but uh it would be interesting to
extend the formulation um to uh
nonlinear projections onto uh polinomial
manifolds uh and uh it it would be
fascinating to be able to do so while
keeping uh the uh while still being able
to compute the gradient uh in close form
and we'll have to see if we're able able
to do that without relying on um
automatic
differentiation um yeah so I'd like to
acknowledge contributions from uh my uh
collaborators and co-authors bla bmer
and Professor Boni at uh uiu and
Professor Bon is my uh postdoc
supervisor and then of course funding
from uh the National Science Foundation
okay well uh thank you for listening and
I'm I'm I'm very happy to take any
questions thank you thank you so much
for the wonderful talk Alberto great job
um okay let's have a Q&A sessions we do
have a question from um the chat having
asked thanks for the talk it was very
interesting can you give us a more
insight explanation on how oblique
projection performs better than
orthogonal projection right right yeah
so let me see if I
can per Okay so
uh from a from a I guess from a I'm
trying to give an answer from a physical
but also mathematical standpoint so
typically when we do orthogonal
projections
uh we we look at pod and and we we use
pod to do so and pod will take
trajectories and look and will give you
a projection onto the features that are
most energetic so for instance in this
simple toy model um uh pod would tell
you that the most energetic states are
X1 and X2 and so we'd be performing uh
we'd be projecting would would the
reduced order model of would be
neglecting uh the state X3 um the
trouble with that is that the state X3
even though is uh is very low energy
because of the case very fast it's
extremely dynamically important because
we see that X3 has a large impact on the
energetic structures so we have a
situation where where we have uh high
energy structures but their Dynamics is
uh very much affected by low energy
structures that procedures like pod
would completely disregard so what an
oblique projection lets you do is it
lets you identify the high energy
Subspace so that will it will give you
fee high energy Subspace but it also
lets the Poss gives you the possibility
of choosing S and S can be chosen in
such a way that it accounts for the fact
that X3 is dynamically important
so when you have a oblique projection
you have uh more degrees of freedom if
you will you have the Subspace where you
project onto and you but but you also
have a Subspace that tells you the
direction along which to project and so
uh by doing that um uh you're capable of
of of that's that's that's Loosely
speaking why oblique projection
operators tend to work better um than
orthal projection operators yeah all
right thank you um next question is by
gel
why is the error consistently higher
near T is equal to zero for example for
slide
27 across the
board is yeah can you go to 27 is this
due to the increased complexity of the
function at all your times which
diminishes later or is there another
Factor contributing to this behavior
that I might be missing right what
happens with
um where am
I um what happens with these models if
you extra Pate to times that your model
hasn't seen uh right uh yeah so so
there's two questions there I guess uh
um the first one is why is the error uh
consistently higher at Early Times okay
so uh
basically
uh oblique in general uh okay so most
most of the contribution to the cost
function error is due to um the the long
time Dynamics uh of the system so for
instance if you if you have a limit
cycle for for example uh a good reduced
order model will be a a model that gives
you the correct amplitude of the uh of
the limit cycle oscillations and the
correct phase and so in order to do that
it might not be necessary to minimize
the error at Early Times well important
is that the ROM
trajectory uh and
the uh is in the correct phase with the
farm trajectory once the farm enters the
low dimensional Subspace so basically it
it it's it's kind of it's kind of a
feature it's kind of a it's kind of
something that we have to live with like
the initial condition that we are giving
that we are looking at might not be
closed to the Subspace uh that we're
projecting uh that we're using for model
reduction uh and we're okay with that uh
what oblique projections allow us to do
is that over time the ROM trajectory and
the farm trajectory will approach each
other and will continue in a
synchronized fashion and so and at that
point the ROM will be very good and the
error will be very low so that's kind of
uh early time errors is is kind of
something that uh there's not much we
can do about because the initial
condition might be far away from the low
dimensional Subspace that we're uh
considering for model reduction so I
hope that answers the question U second
question that we had that uh was uh
extra how does the model perform for
long times uh well as uh it performs
very well I guess so in uh this case for
the toy model we've trained from 0 to 10
uh but uh we're testing uh well the
sosal input uh is is carried out for 30
time units uh and uh so it's three times
the temporal uh extension of the uh yeah
it's like three times the length of the
training uh data set uh and the same
goes for uh the complex G below equation
and the lid driven cavity flow uh we we
we would hope that uh it's kind of
a uh it's important that models are able
to extrapolate in time uh and the the
way to guarantee that is to make sure
that we're actually learning good
Dynamics uh and that we're not of course
over fitting uh once uh once we're
confident that the ROM uh is uh that the
ROM Dynamics and the projection is is
good then uh we tend to observe that the
model is is is is very capable of
extrapolating to to very long times that
uh hadn't seen
before yeah awesome well foll to that I
me your uh examples
are uh statistically periodic or the
deterministically periodic right um
if so if you
are um extrapolating time domains um you
have seen those Data before so it's you
are able to capture that using the self
space you trained uh with the obl
project projections and operator
inference um yeah I I'd like to point
out that uh yes and no uh no in the
sense that we we don't train on periodic
dat data we train on impulses right so
the the type of uh although the the the
information contained within those
impulses is enough yeah that the model
uh figures out uh that uh if you force
sinos Sally you will induce a limit
cycle and with a certain frequency and
amplitude and so that that that that's
why it's uh capable of of of of of of
giving good predictions for for a long
time yeah so uh yeah I I I I I agree
like uh the the the model is uh at the
end of the day as as in with for any
other data driven method uh uh if if the
input is uh you know in distribution
then we expect it to do well if for some
reason we have inputs that uh that no
signature on the training data then uh
the model might fail yeah yeah uh
totally agree um any other
questions um I have a couple of
questions so
all right so before I go to my question
yes uh Fe
fero as two questions he said very
interesting talk uh the his first
question is do you have a follow ative
estimate of the time saving of nitro ROM
compared to the form in the example so
basically speed up is talking about
right um and second question is which
criterian did you use to decide the
dimension of the reduced model uh basis
dimension of 50 great question for the
for for the for the last example I guess
yeah well okay so as far as speed up
goes I haven't computed it but for this
example we have uh okay so this would be
uh two flow variables uh will be 20,000
dimensional not if I'm not
mistaken and so 20,000 degrees of versus
50 I don't know you do the math like a
thousand times
faster roughly depending on yeah it's uh
yeah it's it's quite a bit faster um and
uh um as far as the other okay why why
did you how did you pick the dimension
okay so I picked the dimension by doing
pod first and and and looking at the
decay of the singular values of the
training of the training data set and
the leading 50 modes uh gave us uh I
forget like roughly 99% of the total
variance uh in the in the data so that's
that's that's a very common Criterion to
to pick the the underly ROM Dimension
yeah all right um thank you Kel
ask does it make sense to test this
approach on chaotic equations such as
the Len system that's a fantastic
question
uh um there might be a little bit of uh
difficulties with that uh in that uh
okay uh let's
see um it might it might make sense to
do it I I would actually be very curious
to see what happens but uh one needs to
be careful when Computing the gradient
right uh because uh for uh when we're
Computing the we're integrating the ROM
ad equation in time and so effectively
we're back propagating the error through
uh the through the trajectories if the
system is chaotic then then the then the
gradient will blow up uh so uh there are
uh I'm not too familiar with literature
on how to handle that but I know there
are ways to uh optimize systems uh uh
you know in the presence of of of chaos
so um one might need to do a little bit
of trickery uh to uh to be able to to to
carry out the optimization but um yeah
uh in in principle yes uh I I would
believe that it would make sense to uh
uh to look uh to to apply this
formulation to chaotic systems
yeah thank for thank you um so going
back to my questions my first question
is kind of related to uh what diesel
asked earlier um about you know earlier
times you got higher eror and
um for example you know the leet driven
cavity uh problems um it clearly has a
high energy phase and later on that
energy dies dies out so there um for the
particular problem if you if I have to
divide the the simulation into two phase
you know there's a allly phase and later
phase there's a the concept called the
time window the Ram uh where you can you
know come up with a different set of the
basis for the for different phase so in
the beginning phase you you know tailor
your basis so that it can capture the
high energy better and then later on you
know it's easier problem so you probably
get away with the smaller dimension of
the basis so I I think you know you you
could extend your algorithm to time in
doing framework uh to even uh further
improve the this I uh the the relative
better in the all time phase yeah that's
that's that's a very that's very
interesting thought uh yeah so I guess
that uh that approach would uh let us
maybe uh decrease the initial initial
error due to the fact that the uh that
the initial condition is far away from
the Subspace we're projecting onto but
then we move on to a different Subspace
yeah uh later on time that that's that
yeah that's a great thought um and yeah
I mean there's a more discussions onto
it but um yes that's the basic idea um
and when you go from one phase to the
another phase you could come up with a
some sort of physics indicator depending
on the applications so that that
indicator tells you automatically where
to change from you know first phase to
the second
phase because we don't want to manually
you know cut at this time yes so yeah um
my my second question is okay you have
presented um in the context of the
reproductive case
only and natural Next Step would be the
parameterization like the generalization
of your method um if you can share any
thoughts uh on that because that's
natural next step right right uh yeah so
if we want to have
parametric uh reduced order models I
guess that
what and if I if I had to think about it
really quick how to do it would be to uh
interpolate across in in in parameter
space uh and of course uh we'd have to
be uh we'd have to be careful about how
we do that because we're uh like at each
at each parameter where we actually
perform a fit we we are uh Computing uh
subspaces and elements of of Steal
manifold and so we we we we we'd have to
interpolate on on on those manifolds and
also we'd have to guarantee that uh the
interpolated at uh on once we
interpolate uh we preserve the property
that uh F and S Define define a
projection um yeah so um I guess that th
those would be the the first concerns um
yeah but yeah it's very very much uh
next step on on how to extend it and I
welcome any sort of input you guys are
all experts in in these topics yeah yeah
so there there is a interpolation in s
manifold uh there's a tech for that so I
I can definitely definitely share that
with you but yeah totally agree um you
know interpolation would be a way to go
um yeah for the
parameterizations right awesome okay um
all right is there any other
question okay if not let's thank our
speaker for the wonderful talk thank you
so much Alberto um thank so much thank
you for joining very nice work and after
this talk hopefully there will be more
collaboration between Lawrence Li and
your your I I I would love that let's uh
let's let's keep in touch all right
sounds good okay thanks for having me
again byebye thank you bye